he's von Miller Broncos linebacker super
bowl MVP man about town and he joins us
now is this an off day for you oh yeah
it's office all day you know kinda you
know he's never truly off days they're
gonna do recovery you know get your
extra workout in any type of production
stuff that you may have so it is it is
all day but you know not really now we
were just talking about movies in poly
goes what's the last movie you think von
Miller watch then and do you guys watch
them on Team flights almost a matter of
fact we are rented the movie theater
last night as a matter of fact really um
when watched a couple of movies yeah we
want to watch rivals and we went to
watch Doctor Strange well do you guys
rent out the entire theater it is right
there akata theater right eight of us
all nice and now do you get like free
popcorn like you got your run of the
place did I mean they show us some love
you know things that they can oh you
know but uh you know it's good here to
watch movies um I I don't know if you
saw this last night if you're watching
movies Brady yelling at Julian Edelman
and have you got into a moment where
you're yelling at a teammate on the
sidelines like that the cameras pick it
up oh you know it's you know a football
loser you know it's just where those
sports where you know you gotta show
emotion you know in some place but you
know I try not to rule my teammates you
know some guys on my team that you know
this you know there are you know their
line of communication but for me you
know I try to I try to be patient and
just you know let things work out and
you know I was trying to be the positive
energy on the summer yeah because I know
everybody's looking for perfection and
guys have a way to communicate but you
know Brady got caught on camera yelling
at Julian Edelman and I think people
looking at that and saying you know is
that the way to send a message but I I
feel like if it's the quarterback and
he's the leader and you do something
wrong and he says something to you then
there that's part of the game it was
definitely I mean he's a leader you know
as they've had been working on some of
the some of the things uh you know all
we did you know he probably you don't
mess it up
want to play or whatever it may be it is
just that's the leader anything that's
how he's gonna show you motion how's the
team well we're doing pretty good no no
we should be better you know if we would
have you know one ish I game against the
Tennessee Titans you know we could uh
we'll be spending a lot better right now
but that's the National Football League
that's the beauty international full of
league you got to consistently come in
and ground you got to consistently come
in and prove yourself and you have a
great opportunities we going against one
of the best teams in football what'd you
think of Mariota I like the Mike you
know I was a fan of his decision making
but really we really didn't give them
opportunities to you know throw the ball
because they had so much success running
the ball on the side we really didn't
get to see them you know the pass game
like we wanted to but that's because
they were so successful in the in the
rent game so we got out we got to
tighten up on the run game to them you
know plato's mir stress and that's
passing the ball there's von Miller the
Broncos linebacker they got the Patriots
coming up next week what kind of
relationship you have with Brady I mean
is this value know uh I mean as you can
imagine you necessary so it's a
workplace you know I'm on the field type
of relationship so you know our last
couple of meetings you know they've you
know um been a little bit a little bit
different for you know Tom but um you
know that's our relationship is nothing
you know off the field or anything like
you don't do talk to each other on the
field no I mean I really don't talk to
everyone talk to guys on the football
field I'm so focused on what I need to
do next in I'm always thinking about you
know the next move the next play Oksana
you know get back there how can I set up
this movie to get back there so I'm
always thinking ahead so I really don't
have time to you know sit down there you
know how conversations me a game like
that Vaughn is partnering with digiorno
the pizza folks to create the ultimate
party for fans called rise to the
occasion and you're with the rapper
Redfoo and you know I was with a rifle
in the music videos i pre coo and you're
dancing it definitely usual DiGiorno is
releasing a trailer for the upcoming
hit song and music video that you can
see it dushore know.com anything else we
need to know about this you and red food
talk music or did you talk sports I mean
we talked to it we try to limit of both
way you know I don't really know a lot
about music and you know he's a he
really didn't you know I have a lot
about sports so we had a little bit of
you know conversation there Bo I mean
we're both too you know creative
interesting guy so it was morning it's
more to talk about than just you know
sports and sports and music it's
DiGiorno dot-com rise to the occasion
he's von Miller good luck against the
Patriots good to catch up with you again
von already gosh thank you I appreciate
it all right von Miller the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]